we had a bunch of interesting elections
yesterday a very important reminder
useful reminder that we don't just have
a presidential race going on right now
we have 435 House seat elections coming
up in November
many primaries for those happening in
the months leading up we have 35 Senate
elections and the possibility that
Democrats would be able to take over the
Senate we've looked at that and
yesterday there were a bunch of
interesting primaries that I want to
talk about today
not at all surprisingly congresswoman
Alexandria Castillo Cortes had a primary
challenger who she easily defeated the
Challenger was Michele Caruso Cabrera a
CNBC host former Republican running now
as the Democrat and AOC easily won as of
right now looks like AOC had about 73
percent of the vote in that race because
that's such a blue district the primary
is essentially the general election like
there will be a Republican on the ballot
against AOC in November but the fact
that she won the primary all but
guarantees that AOC will get a second
term in the House of Representatives
another race that we were watching very
closely and we'll continue to watch
closely now that we have a primary
winner is the Democratic challenger
against Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell for his Kentucky Senate seat
Mitch McConnell has been one of the most
successful Republicans from the the the
measurement from the standpoint of what
he's been able to achieve as many of you
know a an excellent and effective tool
for the right in getting a bunch of
judges confirmed holding off holding
open a seat on the Supreme Court that
should have been Barack Obama's to
replace with Merrick garland obstructing
Mitch McConnell that seat for long
enough that Donald Trump ended up
getting to choose Neel Gore such an
incredible coup victory for Republicans
horrible for the world horrible for the
country never should have been allowed
to happen but if you're a Republican
certainly Mitch McConnell has been
effective he has a serious primary
challenge and Amy McGrath seemed to be
the leader going
into the primary over the last couple of
weeks there was some energy around
Charles Booker a more progressive
alternative in the Democratic primary
but indeed Amy McGrath has won there
with about 45% of the vote
that's a plurality Charles Booker only
with about 36% of the vote so we will
see Amy McGrath challenged Mitch
McConnell we've said before it's a very
uphill battle but even getting Mitch
McConnell to have a fight even of
forcing Republicans nationally to have
to spend money to defend Mitch
McConnell's seat is great and she could
actually win Amy McGrath was up by one
point a tie within the margin of error
statistically speaking a couple of weeks
ago that's going to be a great one to
watch interesting Republican primary in
North Carolina to mention where a
24-year old guy defeated the Trump
endorsed candidate in the Republican
primary for a House seat his name is
Madison Kath ORN Trump endorsed his
opponent Linda Bennett this is the 11th
congressional district in North Carolina
that's the seat that was formerly held
by Trump's now latest chief of staff
mark Meadows who's a horrible horrible
guy unofficially Cawthorne won very
easily by about a 75 to 25 margin this
is a notable defeat for the Trump
endorsed candidate but it's important to
remember that the guy that won Cawthorne
he also loves Trump is it Trump endorsed
the the his opponent but this is not
like an anti Trump Republican that one
Catherine loves Trump it's just that
Trump picked somebody else so either way
if he wins in November it's still
horrible interestingly he's not even old
enough to serve as of right now but
because he will be 25 by the time he
would be inaugurated he's allowed to be
on the ballot he will go on to face the
Democratic candidate MO Davis and that's
a Republican leaning district so at a
sort of background level at a base level
that that is one that favors Republicans
there are four congressional
candidates who support Medicare for all
who won primaries yesterday Ritchie
Torres Jamaal Bowman Mondt Air Jones and
Dana Balter so that's interesting and
important and we'll see what happens
with their races in November and then a
really interesting story out of Virginia
dr. Cameron Webb
I call him WebMD that's how I refer to
him but officially dr. Cameron Webb he
have won the Democratic primary in
Virginia's fifth District and he will
probably face off against Republican Bob
good in November that would be a really
great seat to turn from red to blue Webb
ran hugely on affordable health care
he's a physician he was leading with 68%
of the vote last I checked so that's a
big win for him that actually is a
traditionally Republican district which
is flippable and Virginia has been a
what I call it Virginia has been a
realistic focus of going blue we've seen
many elements of Virginia go blue over
the last eight 10 years and officially
that race leans Republican but it is a
winnable seat and we'll just have to see
how the campaign shakes out it's a wild
district in that last election cycle
Republican Denver Riggleman won the seat
by about 6 points and then was removed
by the local Republican convention
because he officiated a gay wedding for
two of his old friends and campaign
staffers which is it it Virginia's been
getting pulled blue it is still Virginia
and this stuff still exists there so a
number of interesting races this ties
into how will we vote in November and
the discussions of absentee ballots and
vote by mail we'll be talking about that
later today the desire for scientists
and educators and doctors at least on
the Democratic side it seems partially
to be related to what we've been seeing
with coronavirus and the failed federal
response in the United States and that's
exactly where I want to go next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinking
cast lets you consume an entire book on
your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do or if you
just want to sample a book before you
buy the entire thing I recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great Stephen Hawking this is a book
that I have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video